it's time to play another game
the saw series is coming back from the
dead with spiral
from the book of saw and this time there
are no rules
if you want to learn more about what to
expect from spiral
well you've come to the right place
you want to play games
the first saw film shocked audiences
back in october 2004
setting the tone for the torturous form
of horror that dominated the genre
during that decade
from 2004 up until 2010 horror fans got
a new saw film
every year as a halloween present with
jigsaw
the eighth installment in the franchise
hitting theaters in 2017.
now we'll get to see what the next
chapter in the book of saw
spiral has in store that spiral is what
i think it is
jigsaw wait i thought the jigsaw killer
was dead yeah but if it's another
copycat
it's going to be it's been a long
journey for the ninth film in the saw
franchise
originally the movie was set for release
in october 2020
but it looks like another senior horror
franchise elbowed its way
back into that territory after the
success of 2018's halloween
michael myers was supposed to return for
everybody's favorite spooky holiday
with follow-up halloween kills which was
originally planned for a 2020 release
most likely not wanting to compete with
the man in the william shatner mask
spiral changed its release date to may
15
2020. of course as we all know
neither horror film made it to theaters
as intended
as the world was turned upside down and
theaters closed by the covet 19 pandemic
however you can't stop a good slasher
franchise from coming back to life
and now spiral from the book of saw is
set to hit theaters and
imax on may 14th 2021
the cast of spiral from the book of saw
sounds pretty impressive
especially for something so outlandish
as a saw movie
first up we've got chris rock whether
you know him from his stand up
his more comedic acting work or his
serious dramatic roles
we can all agree that rock is a
charismatic and thoughtful performer
so it will be super fascinating to see
him take the lead
in a horror franchise as messed up as
the saw series
in fact in a refreshing twist rock
happens to be
one of the major creative forces behind
the film his pitch for the movie
is reportedly responsible for it
existing in the first place
but more on that later in spiral rock
plays
detective zeke banks a cop who's
investigating a new string of gruesome
murders
with some familiar iconography of course
he isn't handling the case alone
rock will be accompanied by max mingela
who will be playing
zeke's rookie partner if you think
mingela looks familiar
that's probably because you've seen him
as nick in the handmaid's tale
both detectives are working for captain
angie garza
played by marisol nichols of riverdale
and 24
fame of course the biggest name involved
is samuel l
jackson the man who brought nick fury
mace windu
and jules winfield to life will be
playing police veteran
marcus banks the accomplished but
estranged father of chris rock's
character
his casting adds a serious hook to a
film some people might otherwise write
off
a ninth saw movie well maybe you feel
like you've seen it before
a saw movie with samuel l jackson though
that's all you had to say
here's where things get really
interesting with this new saw film
the seed for the story came from an
unlikely person
chris rock variety reports that rock
approached some of the producers behind
the saw franchise with his idea for a
new film
and spiral from the book of saw grew
from that concept
joe drake chairman of lionsgate motion
picture group
set of rock's treatment when chris rock
came to us and described in chilling
detail his fantastic vision that
reimagines
and spins off the world of the notorious
jigsaw killer
we were all in honestly we are too
rock wrote the original story for spiral
but he didn't write the film's final
screenplay
pete goldfinger and josh stolberg who
also wrote 2017's jigsaw
adapted rock's story into spiral
screenplay the duo also wrote the
surprisingly fun remake of piranha
in 2010 the saw films vary in quality
and a big part of that is due to how
quickly they were being put together
one film every year is a hectic pace one
aspect that many fans still agree on
however
is that the saw films were in good hands
when director
darren lynn bausman was at the helm he
directed saw 2
saw 3 and saw 4 helping play off the
momentum of the original
and makes saw a household name and now
bausman is back in the director's chair
for spiral
from the book of saw bausman himself
announced that he'd be directing the
film on his instagram
posting an on-set photo from the first
day of production in july 2019
meanwhile long time franchise heads mark
berg
and oren kulas are also involved as
producers
even better still james wan and lee
wannell
the original duo who brought jigsaw to
life and have since given us
modern horror classics like the
conjuring and the invisible man
are serving as executive producers so if
anything is going to help bring the saw
franchise back from the dead
it's this team so how exactly
does spiral from the book of saw fit
into the timeline of the franchise
is it a sequel is it a total reboot well
for answers we can look to the twitter
account of josh stolberg one of the
writers for the film
in 2019 he responded to a curious fan
saying of the new movie it's not a
sequel to jigsaw
it's definitely in the timeline of all
the films though
with that out of the way what's the plot
of this new film
as it turns out spiral is set years
after jigsaw's death but his memory
still
looms large over the world in fact it
seems that he's inspired a copycat
killer one who's targeting cops into
this bloody game
comes chris zeke banks he's a detective
who's been saddled with a rookie partner
and according to the official plot
synopsis is working in the shadow of his
father
you pull a gun on your own man
yeah i could have killed you what are
you talking about i got the gun
i could have killed you but as the
bodies start piling up
zeke is forced to reunite with his
estranged dad to solve this case
and figure out the copycat's motive
which might involve
a twisted form of justice horror and
humor
have a lot in common both relying on
good timing
atmosphere and the right build up of
tension and release
horror has always been closely tied with
humor whether a film is providing
respite from blood and gore
lulling the audience into a false sense
of security or just playing with the
stereotypes of the genre
a good joke can go a long way when it
comes to lightening the mood of an
otherwise
dark movie chris rock isn't always
trying to be funny
but you still might think that his
involvement in spiral from the book of
saw
could make for a movie that's a bit
lighter in tone than the rest of this
relentlessly bleak series but it seems
like that isn't entirely the case
speaking with ign rock said that spyral
will have some humorous
elements mainly because the franchise
was completely lacking them
he said i love saw but i was like wow it
has almost no humor
at all so it seemed like a good place
good fertile ground
saying that he'd already seen a rough
cut of the movie he reported
it's still saw it's bloody it's gory but
there's like a sprinkling of humor here
and there we're not revamping it
it's not scary movie it's saw of course
he wants us to cut through our feet
you go first every horror franchise
has its big bad the friday the 13th
movies have jason
the nightmare on elm street movies have
freddy krueger
and the saw series has john cramer aka
the jigsaw killer granted he died back
in the third film
but his legacy still haunts the
franchise as his apprentices keep
popping up to
play nasty games with unwilling
participants
but will jon kramer appear in spiral
from the book of saw
well maybe in one of the trailers we see
a stack of photos and if you're paying
close attention
you'll notice that one of them is jigsaw
himself so at the very least
we'll see a very literal snapshot of the
man but will actor tobin bell
actually reappear somehow well in a
collider interview back in october 2020
bell was asked if he was psyched for the
film and if he would reprise his iconic
role
his answer oh yeah i'm excited for it
but it's not something i can really talk
about at this particular moment
well that's an interesting answer indeed
based on that response alone
it seems belle very well might be
involved with spiral
granted the movie isn't listed on bell's
imdb
page and he hasn't shown up in any of
the promotional materials aside from
that one
old photograph most importantly his
character is dead
but when does that stop the slasher
villain from coming back
after all cramer showed up in 2017's
jigsaw via flashbacks
so maybe bell will return for one last
game
at the very least john cramer's
influence will be
all over this film as his copycat starts
a new reign of terror
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one